morning to you the government is to hold
more crisis talks with the energy
regulator today over rising gas prices
the business secretary says there's no
cause for immediate concern over the
uk's gas supply amid concerns that some
energy firms will go bust and household
bills could jump by as much as 400
pounds a year the meat industry is also
warning about the knock-on effects of
price rises a shortage of carbon dioxide
means they can't slaughter animals
humanely and shoppers can expect empty
shelves unless action is taken
nick martin has the latest
for the second day in a row the business
secretary quasi kwa tang will have
meetings about rising gas prices and the
impact that that could have on
households here in britain yesterday of
course he held meetings with operators
but it all culminated in saying that he
thought that the security of gas supply
in the united kingdom was not a cause
for immediate concern he said the gas
system continues to operate and he
thought it would continue to operate
reliably as we go into the winter months
he also said that he didn't expect gas
supply emergencies this winter the tone
of what the business secretary said
suggested that he had been reassured by
his meetings but today he'll want to
know what the impact is on households
the fear of course is that a gas supply
shortage which will lead to price hikes
will be passed on by the companies to
households and this already comes at a
time when inflation has seen its biggest
rise in on record this august and all
sorts of costs arising like food and
fuel so he will want reassurances as to
how this will impact on the british
people we already know that the energy
price cap is in place to protect people
and he'll want some reassurances about
that as well but of course this comes at
a time where britain is experiencing
supply problems we already have a
shortage of heavy goods vehicles caused
in part by covid and the pandemic and
brexit but of course we're also seeing
shortages of food on shelves and
companies trying to keep the supply
chain moving all of the ingredients are
now lining up which would suggest that
we are heading towards a crisis gas is
extremely in short supply the price is
rising every day quasi quarten on behalf
of the government will want some
reassurances that this will not develop
into a serious situation which will need
real attention
well mr tang said last night that
volatile gas prices underscore the need
for more investment in renewable energy
the prime minister is to hold meetings
in new york and washington on monday to
try to galvanize action on climate
change ahead of the cop 26 summit in
glasgow boris johnson will make a speech
at the un general assembly and then head
to the white house for his first visit
since president biden took office
he said he'd be pushing world leaders to
take concrete action on coal climate
cars and trees
now more than a million people in
england will be sent an invitation this
week to get a coronavirus booster jab uh
if you are included on that list you've
got to be at least six months after your
second vaccine to be eligible let's talk
to milena vasilinovich who's in the
newsroom so who falls under this who's
eligible for a booster
well it's the same as first time round
it's people aged 50 yeah those living
and working in care homes the front line
health and social care staff as well as
anyone who is clinically extremely
vulnerable and anyone at age 16 or over
who is at particular risk of covet but
what's quite interesting is that
regardless of what vaccines they had
first the booster jab will be either the
pfizer or half a dose of moderna people
will only get the astrazeneca as a
booster if they're allergic to any of
the ingredients in the other two jabs
now we don't know the full reasons
behind this because the research into
different combinations of vaccines can't
be published for commercial reasons
there are some clues however the
scientists working on this trial said
that some combinations of vaccines
showed a severalfold increase in
antibodies you can assume is the ones
that they chose and astrazeneca also has
been linked to some very rare but
potentially life-threatening blood clots
so you have to wonder whether that may
have informed some of the
decision-making by the joint committee
on vaccination and immunization but this
is all part of the government's plan to
try to prepare for what they said could
be a bumpy winter ahead and the hope is
that if you give the most vulnerable in
society that extra layer of protection
with a booster jab it will be hopefully
enough to keep a lid on infections and
avoid any restrictions
this winter
okay milena thank you well let's talk to
dr graham jackson senior clinical
advisor at the nhs confederation good to
see you this morning um how important is
this booster vaccine for those who are
being singled out for it
i think it's crucial and crucial for
those individuals and for the system as
your correspondent has said there uh the
burden of covert is going up uh to make
to if we contain that that illness then
will help to reduce the overall pressure
uh the evidence has been as
said and shown by the jcbi there's a
waning of uh some
you know immortalization
and boosting at this stage means it
makes sense to try and overall hold the
infection in control
i mean in in terms of of the the sort of
mixed jab approach which is well going
to apply to those people who haven't
already had the fisa vaccine i mean
we know there's been a lot of research
that's been going on about mixing the
vaccines
are you confident that does produce a
better immune response
i think i'm as comfortable as anybody
else's i'm not the expert i'm not the
virologist i'm not on the jcbi looking
at the data
we've got confidence that the
specialists have looked at this data and
it's a decision they made
this is made because we want to get the
best penetration of of cover we need to
make sure we've got the most people are
immunized to the highest level which
keeps our infection rates down keeps our
hospitalizations down and keeps our
mortality rate down
at least you
with all of this when there's a lot of
talk about uptake at the moment
particularly amongst a younger age group
i guess you can be pretty confident with
this that uptake is because of the
people you're targeting here
that uptake is going to be high
well i would hope so certainly uh this
this first group and and that expanded
out uh we've seen very good uptake in
the first uh uh primary and second
of kovid we're going into the flu season
as well so we've got opportunity people
coming up for their flu vaccinations so
um and then where possible those were
given together that may not always be
the case uh so i think we are we've seen
really good coverage although we want to
make sure the coverage is as best as
possible getting as many people as
immanises is the aim
um
in terms of of
the logistics of this how how much of a
strain does that put on the nhs i mean
to you you talk about the flu
vaccination if they can combine those
vaccination clinics that's one thing but
it has the potential at least of being
quite quite a a
a difficult situation doesn't it putting
on even more vaccination clinics
absolutely let's not underestimate the
challenge of the logistics of doing this
at a time when the nhs is already under
significant pressure all aspects
i don't need to tell you all aspects of
nhs are under pressure
but
that extra bit of effort to get these
vaccinations through to try and turn the
curve on the cove
disease reduce the
cases there are out there will reap
benefit in the longer term you know the
workload is there from a multi-faceted
environment it's the backlog all the
stuff that you know fluid coming into
the winter
if we can contain the coved aspect of
that by giving these vaccinations then
the extra investment in time is well
worth it
i mean what is concerning i guess for a
lot of people watching is the the fact
that we we we feel like we've we've
turned the curve on this already and
that's the sort of general sense within
in the country now that we've you know
coming we're out of lockdown and things
are getting much more back to normal i
mean
how real is the danger that
with winter coming on we could actually
find ourselves back in hot water
so i think we have to take it as a real
a real danger absolutely the country's
opening up sort of socially we turned
we've changed the way we behave but in
fact there's other pressures going with
winter and this as you well have heard
we've talked about this being the summer
in winter this year around the number of
vaccines a number of illnesses and the
demand but other illnesses will come
through as well there's respiratory
illness in children coming through we
may have flu coming through so
as part of the whole picture it's
important that we do try and contain
this virus
the data is showing a slight upturn at
the moment
have been reported on a daily basis
and we can turn that round again and
make sure this is not a significant
factor going into the winter and
alongside all the other diseases we have
to look up have to manage and look after
okay dr jackson good to talk to you
thank you
thank you much
now the new foreign secretary has
weighed in on the deepening row over the
new security pact involving the uk the
us and australia writing in the sunday
telegraph liz trust says the trilateral
agreement shows the uk's readiness to be
hard-headed in defending our interests
france though is furious of being
excluded from the agreement and losing
out on a multi-billion dollar submarine
contract the elysee palace has recalled
ambassadors from the u.s and australia
and accused the uk
of permanent opportunism
well trevor phillips spoke to the former
u.s defense secretary leon panetta who
said the french should be more
supportive
the deal that you signed with the uk and
australia has made the french furious
the french foreign minister described it
as a stab in the back and the elysee
palace has uh recalled its ambassador to
the united states
this is a misstep isn't it
well you know i i'm i'm not sure of just
exactly what kind of conversations went
on
uh with regards to our allies
france and others as well
i would hope
that when this kind of partnership is
announced
that
our other allies would support that kind
of partnership because very frankly
the role of allies is to build
partnerships
and to be able to work together
when it comes to security
when it comes to
our economics when it comes to trade etc
that that's that's the heart and soul
of having allies let me just ask you
this though
that the french said that uh the this
behavior
looks like something that mr trump would
do isn't that the biggest insult that
anybody could level at a biden white
house
well
yeah and it's probably not accurate
because
i'm not sure that
president trump
had the ability to develop the kind of
partnerships
that the biden administration developed
in this case the kind of strategic
partnership
between the united kingdom
australia and the united states uh that
was not something that trump was very
interested in doing so but you see my
point
it is a it's a criticism but i don't
think it's based on fact
and you can see that full interview in
trevor phillips on sunday trevor's also
going to be talking to the president of
cop 26
alex sharma that all starts at half
eight this morning
the prime minister has been accused of
having a casual approach to britain's
national security in a highly critical
report by mps
westminster's joint committee on
national security strategy says the
government is unable to cope with more
than one major crisis at a time
and says the fall of afghanistan
revealed the current system's inadequacy
the whole purpose of the national
security council is to be able to pull
back from the crisis of the moment and
try to think longer term and more
strategically
and afghanistan is a case in point
because we knew certainly since april
that president biden was going to go
ahead and complete the pull-out
by at the end of august if the
government was caught short by the rapid
deterioration then i think questions do
need to be asked
a two-year-old girl has died after
falling from a pony during a hunt
meeting in north yorkshire the toddler
fell on wednesday morning while riding
with members of the bee dale hunt in
north allerton
she passed away in hospital on thursday
police say her family are getting
specialist support whilst inquiries are
ongoing
the trial of a new drug to be a form of
breast cancer has been described as
groundbreaking astrazeneca said the new
drug showed a 72 reduction in the
disease progressing or leading to death
compared to other medicines
researchers have also made progress in
the treatment of incurable bowel cancer
identifying a possible new medication
it's called
uh adivositive it will be taken as a
pill and could potentially delay tumor
regrowth for those patients with limited
treatment options
a hospital in the midlands plans to
become the first in england to run
entirely on renewable energy plans for a
giant solar farm to directly power the
hospital have now been given the
go-ahead the trust says it'll save
millions in energy bills that can be
invested back into patient care
becky johnson reports
[Music]
if the question is how to power a major
hospital with renewable energy you don't
expect to find the answer on a disused
landfill site in the black country but
this former tip will be transformed into
a giant solar farm panels stretching
across the site the size of 21 football
pitches as you can see it's just
derelict land which was landfill for
many years the idea to turn it into a
power source for wolverhampton's biggest
hospital came about due to a battle to
get funding it's toxic land we can't
build an air but one of the projects
we've looked at is a solar farm so it's
something we very much wanted to do to
supply clean energy sadly we we just
couldn't get the funding streams
available but the nhs could so working
together they came up with the plan to
cable the site exclusively to new cross
hospital the huge benefits to the
hospital is that we will be able to
power
all of our electronic needs for the site
from the solar farm so we feel it's an
absolute win-win in terms of monetary
sides of things this could
generate savings of somewhere in the
order 15 to 20 million pounds over the
next 20 years and that money will be
pushed straight back to the front line
in terms of health care
and those much needed funds will be
freed up soon
the time scale for the project is tight
it's hoped this hospital could be fully
running on renewable energy by spring of
next year
existing green energy sources including
the heat generated by the hospital's
waste incinerator will provide
additional power but the majority will
be solar
clean green and cost effective what's
happening here a model for other cities
in the race to cut emissions
it's a very good example of how
different organizations who maybe until
now just had a sort of relationship of
paying the rates and getting the bins
collected sort of thing need to think
differently about how they can
join together to work in a shared
purpose which is net zero
a city with a history of heavy industry
proving an unlikely trailblazer on the
path to a greener future
becky johnson sky news wolverhampton
now for space tourists have ended their
trail blazing trip to orbit earth with a
splashdown in the atlantic off the
florida coast
comes
the spacex capsule contained the first
all amateur crews to circle the world
without a professional astronaut on
board
this is not going to be good for you a
couple from dudley in the west midlands
got the friday their life after they
found a snake in the bedroom
police were called to handle the
situation and used batons to lift the
snake into a shoebox covered in holes it
was later identified as a five-foot
female python with a couple saying they
had no idea how it got there
what would you do
what would you do terrify
uh now let's look at the weather for you
it's going to be some rather heavy
thunderstorms for some of us today
fairly unsettled over the coming week as
well once any mist and fog clears it
should be a bright start across ireland
and northern ireland as well as
southeast england elsewhere slightly
more mix some patchy cloud around some
showers as well
for the morning then the odd shower
could pop up just about anywhere but
central england will see some
particularly heavy downpours and then in
the afternoon more showers breaking out
this time the heaviest will be across
eastern england some of those downpours
heavy thundery slow moving and it could
trigger some localized flooding in
places carly jones is now good to see
you this morning how important has it
been
for lockdown during lockdown for you to
to sort of experience and try out
different styles of music
i think i mean this album was it was
such a challenge to make an album of
this sort during
such a trialling time for all artists
across the world
but
coming out of this now it feels like
such a celebration of music i mean i'm
having the opportunity to sing with
artists that have inspired me for years
so it really does celebrate music across
all genres i'm i'm not just performing
and duetting with tenors as you would
normally hear sopranos do i'm singing
with people like tony hadley elaine page
who's been
a huge inspiration to me from as long as
i can remember paul carrick
uh you've just seen brimacano mason who
is also from nottingham so that's very
special it's um it feels something
really really special in it i suppose
it's a way of saying
music's back and we're all back here
together do you think because we've all
had a bit more time in our hands to try
out new things just talking about the
emmys and all the sort of tv box sets
we've been watching do you think we've
listened to different sorts of music as
well
absolutely i mean it's really
interesting how
we've all suddenly had the time to be
able to listen to music in a way you
wouldn't normally do
very often music sort of becomes
something that happens to be background
sound you know on your on your trip into
work or or wherever else you might be
traveling to because it's obviously
something that
we actively listen to in our cars or
while we're moving around in our day and
i suppose now we've had the time to be
able to
key into lyrics
and it's also been a an extremely
important time to remember how important
art
across the whole artistic spectrum is
for all of us to enrich our lives
yeah i i i'm quite intrigued by the fact
you're going to malta
um later on this week aren't you taking
part in a you know a concert to
celebrate queen one of my one of my very
favorite bands and you're going to be
performing barcelona now
that's tricky isn't it because you've
got obviously not only the the the late
great freddie mercury but also the late
great monster at caballer i mean it's
that's a very tough act to follow to try
to emulate
absolutely i've been having a ball
practicing the song here it's it's very
fortunate i live on a farm and there's
no other houses
um too close to mine because i think i
would have drove a village insane
practicing all of the different
scales up and down that happens in
barcelona it's so decorative but we've
got sheep at the moment and they seem to
have been enjoying it so so far so good
oh yeah i'd love it you could live next
to me i'd love to listen to that all day
long um you talk about living on a farm
you the countryside is very important to
you isn't it
yes i've i've just recently become an
ambassador for
cpre which is
a foundation helping to protect rural
areas here in wiltshire which is where
i'm based
so i still feel quite a novice with that
but it's something that i'm really
excited about and i look forward to be
able to learning more and also sharing
that with other people on my channels
yeah lovely stuff do you know i i love
hearing a bit of a nottingham chatwang
i went to uni in nottingham and it just
takes me back it's lovely to hear that
on the tv again carly good to see you
this morning thank you oh thank you very
much
can't beat a nottinghamshire accent
love it let's look at the weather for
you now i don't think it's going to be
great if you're in nottingham actually
there's some rather heavy thunderstorms
for some of us today fairly unsettled
over the coming weeks so should be a
bright start for ireland and northern
ireland and southeast england but it is
more mixed elsewhere patchy cloud around
some showers in the morning we're going
to see the odd shower pop up almost
anywhere but it looks like it is going
to be central england which sees some
particularly heavy downpours for the
afternoon more showers breaking out the
heaviest in eastern england some of
those could be heavy thundery and
slow-moving so it could trigger some
localized flooding
political editor of the sunday mirror
nigel nelson and the entrepreneur joanna
jensen good to see you both nigel can we
start with the sunday express front page
indeed we can and
this is about boris johnson flying to
new york today
to speak at the un general assembly
uh but of course the real business will
be done later when he goes to the white
house
and that's to try and mend bridges with
joe biden
after relations between the u.s and
britain sad over afghanistan
this is this is a really important
meeting that now we're out of europe uh
britain really does need the us more
than ever
uh we need it for trade we need it for
defense and a kind of big brother to our
little brother
uh to try and keep up our status in the
world but we do also need within that
that sort of dynamic we need the usa to
listen to us don't we not just
be that puppy
well absolutely i mean that's what we'd
hoped for um but we i just think we have
to accept that the uh as far as the
special relationship goes an unfortunate
term which the us tend not to use
um as far as that goes that we really
are the junior partner
and so um
i know there's a lot of criticism of
this in in this country
but at the end of the day what boris
johnson really needs is the support of
joe biden
if he's to make a success of post-brexit
britain yeah um
joanna what's um the the times got
another a crash diet for britain
uh that's right in this is this is in
the business section and it's telling us
that britain needs to go on a crash diet
and this is all down to the lack of
labor um force particularly hitting
farming
um the
average wage there is 9.35 an hour and
even with a million jobs going begging
at the moment
935 isn't attractive so what we're
seeing now is apple's courgettes being
left to rot in the fields rather than
being picked
because it's not cost effective to get
to get them out of
to harvest them so
couple that with the gas price increases
couple that with kovid brexit it's
making for a perfect storm when it comes
to supplying supermarkets and then you
have this logistics crisis and i call it
a crisis my own business is affected by
the the the
the absolute inability to get product to
warehouse and then from warehouse to
store you're looking at a pretty grim
future in the next few weeks and
certainly leading up to christmas when
it comes to supplying supermarkets and
other retailers it's interesting you say
yeah a million jobs on the go but but
people don't want them because that
we're not paying enough
now if if we pay more that means we've
got to pay more in the supermarkets have
we been over reliant in the past on we
talked about all the the the labor from
europe but have we been over reliant on
just
labor which has been too cheap
i think there is some of that but it's
it's very much the way that this country
has worked and we've it's allowed us to
bring in um people who who aren't able
to work in their own countries aren't
able to find work in their own countries
and are willing to do these jobs here
which is amazing
we as a nation have been incredibly
spoiled i think and now we're finding
we're paying for this and i think we are
going to find ourselves having to take
different jobs and jobs that maybe
aren't as attractive as we'd hoped
yeah michael it's interesting um to the
sunday telegraph nigel and the dreaded
smart motorways
yeah this is another another story about
the dangers of smart smart motorways
where the hard shoulder is replaced by a
fourth lane uh in this case it was a
horse box which broke down on the m6 um
and before that there was any chance to
actually close the the lane
uh it was hit by a lorry and the show
jumper disney
uh had to be extricated in a sort of
five hour operation
uh to get him out of the wreckage and
had to be put down
um the problem really is that smart
motorways really aren't terribly smart
that too often
the inside lane doesn't get closed
quickly enough
and a number of people have been been
killed what there needs to be is an
urgent review
to either
make them safe or abandon the wretched
things altogether i mean i have to say
so i drive along the motorway every day
coming to work and there's there's
always one section which is sometimes a
lane and sometimes isn't but people seem
to drive down it whatever the signs say
nowadays i mean it's hugely dangerous at
times you do wonder how there aren't
more accidents
well exactly which is which is why what
you really need is to keep the hard
shoulder i mean the idea is there are
pull-off points but if you break that
break down uh somewhere between those
pull-off points actually what you're in
is a live lane and you're at huge risk
when that happens yeah yeah it seems do
you agree in agreement with that joanna
i am too often i say i read about these
terrible stories and and it happens all
the time it's not just headline making
news it does happen quite frequently and
i think we need to look again i agree
with nigel wholeheartedly here it's
interesting that they just seem
determined to press ahead with that come
what may um
let's have a look at musicians in the
afghan musicians in particular joanna in
the sunday telegraph
yeah well this is in the arts section
and
you know this is sadly something we all
take for granted but musicians in
afghanistan have now been silenced
because the taliban incorrectly believed
that the quran tells them that music is
it should be outlawed
and so what we're hearing is is another
part of afghanistan being silenced so
their traditional loot the rabb
um has has been shut down and it's it's
now actually really a metaphor for the
whole of the afghani peoples um that
they are unable to speak and voice
anything without fear for their lives
and terrible stories about individuals
really having to move house um and and
actually one particular woman fearful
that she's actually being poisoned by
her family simply because she's a
musician
um nigel in the sunday mirror uh
lgbt cenotaph
yes i mean it it's uh astonishing to
think that although
uh homosexuality was legalized in this
country in 1967.
it remained illegal in the armed forces
until 2000
and that meant that lgbt um uh gay men
and lesbians were uh chucked out of the
uh out of the forces uh some of them
went to jail
as a result of investigations
others had medals ripped off their
uniforms in cruel shaming ceremonies
uh and now at last that they that um the
the the forces seem to be getting their
act together when it comes to
uh gay and lesbian recruits and their
support group fighting with pride has
won the right for the first time this
remembrance sunday
for one of their contingents to place a
wreath um at the cenotaph in front of
the queen
which is you know it's a huge advance
that and it's terribly symbolic
and will be a proud moment for them
uh it'll also be incredibly emotional
for them too
yeah but of course there is a sense
within a lot of i mean
gay people serving in the military now
who who don't want to be singled out in
any way they just want to be part of the
part of the team and and and sexuality
not even be considered
no i mean that's it but i think that the
case is that um that is exactly what is
happening at the moment that the uh the
forces are very open we're probably one
of the best in the world for that now
um but these are veterans who whose fur
before 2000
and their treatment was absolutely
appalling they lost pensions as a result
of doing that and what they want and i
think rightly
is they want an apology from boris
johnson for how they were treated they
want royal pardons rather like the code
breaker alan turing was given
and most of all they want to get some of
the some compensation for the pensions
that they've lost for being chucked out
yeah yeah it's i'm surprised that hasn't
happened already to be honest
um let's have a look at the sun on
sunday just to finish off joanna and
liam gallagher and a helicopter
well you see this is it the life of the
rich and famous it's not all sunshine
and caviar um a recent old white
festival this weekend um liam gallagher
fell out of his helicopter um face
planted and is sporting a very bruised
and damaged face
so you know it's not very rock and roll
is this oh
they're not 100 sure it was either two
or from the isle of wight festival um
someone's actually sort of purported
that maybe he face planted actually on
the helicopter itself as he was running
to you know energetically get into it
but poor chap looks a little bit bruised
and damaged he does he does but it only
adds to his reputation of being the bad
boy of music so i'm sure he'll be all
right
dear me
shouldn't get in the helicopter lovely
it's been good to see you both this
morning thank you very much indeed
do you stay with us here on sky news
breakfast coming up we're going to be
talking more about energy prices and
there's some real concern about what
could happen to gas prices so the
government's holding more crisis talks
with the energy regulator today
as gas prices
soar that'll bring in a whole host of
concerns not only about the bills that
we're going to have to pay what it's
doing to meet production and packaging
in the uk on top of all the other
shortages we're seeing at the moment and
indeed could energy firms themselves
struggle to survive
we'll bring you the very latest
in just a moment